[Musik]
patricia platin sagt ganz klar home
office ist für uns im moment eine
absolute katastrophe für durch sein
ticker steht fest die arbeitswelt wird
sich durch corona verändern
charlotte würdig kritisiert home office
stresst eltern und ist ungesund unser
gast uschi glas behauptet der
metzgersfrau nutzt home office gar
nichts so sieht's aus verschiedene
emotion natürlich auch zu diesem thema
arbeitsminister hubertus heil fordert
eine recht auf home office für alle
das sagt dann das ist seine löwen das
überhaupt darum uns nach hause kommst du
zu hause aber ich kann auch nicht
verstehen wie man so sehr an den
menschen vorbei gehen kann
5 125 prozent sind derzeit im
home-office normalerweise 12 prozent der
menschen der neue zahlen bekommen haben
allein 308.000 neue arbeitslose durch
die korona krise die coburger hat uns an
bevor wir weiter diskutieren was er
genau gesagt tage haltbar
wo es betrieblich möglich ist soll jeder
arbeitnehmer dass künftig einfordern
können
man darf entweder komplett auf home
office umsteigen oder auch nur für ein
oder zwei tage glücklich ich finde es
ist in der derzeitigen situation es
steht halt nicht jeder zu hause und
bauten flipchart auf und hat einen sohn
konferenz sondern das gros der menschen
sitzt in der kasse am band wie frau
gerne auch gerade richtig sagte den
nützt home office überhaupt gar nichts
und selbst na ich sitze zu hause mit
drei kindern also und einem
anschuldigung der soll nicht vergessen
seine aber also nichtsdestotrotz wir
streiten uns darum wer arbeiten gehen
darf ja also wer wäre vorschlägt home
office gesetzlich zu verankern hat also
für für und damit familien zu entlasten
hat weder verstanden was es bedeutet
kinder zu betreuen
noch hat verstanden was es bedeutet zu
arbeiten und dass das eben ohne hilfe
nicht zu sagen geht und da hilft auch
kein gesetz wie der arbeitsminister
vorschlägt aber dort freue ich mich ja
kaum zu widersprechen und trotzdem okay
ich los ich merke auch das positive
momentum es ist definitiv
digitalisierungs schub da zumindest für
alle die sich damit auskennen
da bin ich dankbar für die mitarbeiter
die wir haben weil die kompetenz besitze
ich nicht
und natürlich sind diese fragen also
interessant ist ja was plötzlich alles
geht während dieser krise auch fragen so
ein danach ich bin mir ganz sicher ist
das arbeitsleben nach corona eigentlich
nicht gleich zeigen an wie willst du das
in welchem film haben was kreis willst
du das geld wieder aufgenommen sage ich
bin schauspielerin ich möchte gern
deswegen gilt nicht für alle menschen
und nicht für alle berufsgruppen das ist
sich selbst erklärt aber noch einmal
warum gibt es home office damit wir und
das müssen wir immer wieder betonen dass
infektion risiko ein denn für all die
die dass sich nicht leisten können also
auch die wählerschaft eines hubertus
heil sage ich mal ob er mit sozusagen an
die man auch denken muss die müssen
natürlich eben auch hygienemaßnahmen zur
verfügung gestellt bekommen damit sie
weiterhin diese arbeit nachgehen können
ich meine es gibt vieles richtige da und
so weiter so wird ich frage mich aber
eher warum sagt er dass das ist so also
dass diese aussage brauche ich will noch
im kopf gerade die macht bringt mich
überhaupt nicht weiter deswegen das
frage ich mich wann das gerät zudem
zugesagt
natürlich beliebt mit so etwas na ja
jeder sagen geht eigentlich um flexibles
arbeiten lasse mich in eine nicht gegen
die gestiegenen aber das wird das wollte
er eigentlich wollte eigentlich glaube
ich deutlich machen dass er die menschen
hat weil natürlich geht uns gerade auf
das wir flexibler arbeiten müssen da ich
glaube auch vätern geht gerade auch ja
ich habe ja noch eine familie ist ja
toll endlich auch gerne mal zu hause
oder hat man auch den ehefrauen gehen
vielleicht schon lange auf die in
teilzeitarbeit nur ich würde gerne mehr
arbeiten und du kannst ja mal in
teilzeit ich glaube dass gerade viele
gedanken an er wollte glaube ich genau
da reinstecken aber es war natürlich
eine nachhaltig gemeinen werden weil uns
zu konkretisieren
ich meine wenn wir das home-office nicht
zur verfügung gestellt hätten bei uns
hätte ich ganz viel in die kurzarbeit
schicken müssen
das musste ich aufgrund dessen nicht wir
mussten natürlich flexibel sein dh die
werte dialoge sind umgestellt worden
auch virtuelle werte dialoge die
arbeitseffizienz ist beispiellos ich
habe das gefühl dass wir viel mehr
leisten als es vorher der fall war es
wie bei münchen in teilzeit und ich
haben unternehmen da habe ich nur
working moms beschäftigen die arbeiten
alle von zu hause aber schon auch vor
corinna dass da gibt es überhaupt bei
mir gar kein zweifel daran dass home
office effektiv ist ich finde im moment
ist es halt war es einfach find ich im
falschen zeitpunkt falsche äußerungen
und ich kann es ihm wirklich aber nicht
abnehmen
ich erwarte einfach von dem
arbeitsminister wenn zahlen kommen das
10,1 millionen menschen in kurzarbeit
gerade sind wenn er alleine die gastro
szene anschauen 95% ich bin es ja dass
wir uns jetzt um 25 prozent der menschen
ist in acht millionen also mehr eben
auch nicht große zahl aber eben im
gesamten gesehen nicht das kann nicht
gerade das problem sein es muss eben auf
die geschaut werden den es gerade ganz
anders geht ja das muss natürlich
einheitlich einhergeht aber wie gesagt
wir konnten arbeit zu sichern
durch das hochmoor durch das ich das
nochmal zu tun also da gibt es immer
zwei seiten
ja weil es bei euch möglich ist genau
deswegen sage ich ja das empfinde ich
sie sozusagen auch als luxus debatte in
anführungsstrichen ja aber trotzdem geht
es ja da auch einen sozialen mehrwert
nämlich auch um junge menschen da
draußen die wir jetzt auch stark
motivieren müssen und die wir nicht im
stich lassen dürfen also vielleicht noch
mal ein wichtiger aspekt dass wir nicht
nur alles auch diese staatlichen
institutionen lang lenken und auf
antworten warten sondern selbst auch als
solidargemeinschaft mit gutem beispiel
vorangehen müssen wir sehr ihn
eigentlich ins büro
und so oft es geht hätte ich heute hier
heute sei mit seiner urlaubstag
ich möchte mal ganz kurz zurück wir
reden über home offices homeschooling
das ist natürlich totale gegensätzlich
das ist einfach fast unmöglich das
merken jetzt alle du ganz besonders ja
wir haben eine große sorgen weil wir
normalerweise 11 über 11.000 kinder
jeden tag versorgen wie dem frühstück in
ganz deutschland und das ist einfach
nicht möglich ist und wir finden keinen
weg zu den kindern zukommen wir wissen
dass die kinder natürlich diese sage
immer 11.000 kinder genauso wenig zu
essen haben wie sie normalerweise haben
wenn sie in die schule kommen und kein
abendessen hatten kein frühstück ein
pausenbrot und erst mittag zu essen
bekommen da kriegen sie von uns das
frühstück das ist das eine und das
andere ist dass unsere senioren die 1400
menschen die für uns arbeiten jetzt ja
auch ausgesperrt sind und wir nicht
wissen wie wir jetzt das auf die reihe
kriegen dass wir damit wir die kinder
wieder versorgen können dass die kinder
eben sich verlassen können sie gehen in
die schule holen sie von mir die
hausaufgaben ab und nehmen einfach dann
in kästchen eine box mit wo einfach
essen drin ist und wir kriegen es im
moment einfach nicht gebacken
weil es natürlich so viele probleme gibt
es mir schon klar aber eben ich gehe
davon aus dass es eben diesen kindern
die immer not leiden die sowieso
abgehängt werden weil sie eben auch
nicht einmal die hausaufgaben abholen
von der schule und dann auch nichts zu
essen haben und keine wärme haben keine
geborgenheit fühlen ich werde das ist
für mich ein so großes problem das sich
über andere sachen ehrlich gesagt im
moment das habe ich auch bei den
vorgesprächen mit andere sachen ob
urlaub oder so gar nichts anfangen kann
weil ich so unter druck stehe weil ich
einfach weiß wir können im moment nichts
machen
wir haben natürlich auch nicht die
adressen weil wir beliefern ja die
schulen also ich datenschutz etc
wir kommen an die kinder nicht dran und
ich bin sicher es geht in so schlecht ja
glaube dieses problem wurde viel zu spät
erkannt ja erst heute hat man hat sich
ja die bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten jetzt mal wirklich
konkret dieses themas angenommen
in aussicht gestellt auch mal
entscheidungen zu treffen was die
schulen und die kitas angeht genau die
kinder das ebit die einzige rettung
hören ich spaßeshalber von meiner
überforderung zu hause sprechen
euro retten dann gibt es eben all die
anderen familien für die kinder das
einzige highlight ist eben in die kita
zu gehen andere kinder zu sehen und spaß
zu haben ja und die kinder segnet sich
nach schule ich meine das jahr über so
viel zeit wie die wollen in die
schwierigen jahr war dass wir viele
kinder ihr gewordenen raum ist ihr raum
wo sich wohlfühlt wo ihre lehrerin ist
oder wo unser frühstück ist und uns
senioren die ein bisschen familienersatz
geben die einfach die kinder auch an
meinen arm nehmen und darf mir jetzt
alles nicht aber sagen wir einfach sagen
wir denn heute grundsätzlich erzähl mir
was war denn da los und so diese ganzen
geschichten können jetzt wochenlang
wochenlang nicht stattfinden und wie
gesagt ich habe aber dafür muss er doch
eine lösung gegen sie kann ja auch nicht
sein dass man jetzt die ganze zeit
darüber diskutiert ob wir alle
nachmachen können irgendwie in drei
jahren aber der sand solche stationen
hängen bleiben und ich ja ich sage die
klagen auf dem hohen niveau jeder darf
bei sich anfangen jeder darf was ich
gucken aber man darf natürlich man muss
auch mal ein bisschen dass die
prioritäten setzen und natürlich sind
auch unsere politiker im home-office
stelle ich mir aber ein bisschen anders
vor als bei dir oder bei mir im
schlimmsten fall bei deinen geschichten
wir ja gerade deswegen hatten ja auch
die frauen zu wort kommen und die mütter
also hat ja auch wirklich darum wer
dominiert gerade diese corona debatte
und die ist sozusagen ohne dass ich da
jetzt ein keil zwischen treiben will
schon auch sehr männerlastig und ich
finde es wichtig ja dass auch mütter
alleinerziehende betroffene viel mehr zu
wort kommen und dabei berücksichtigt
werden die familienministerium
ministerin frau gefallen hat er ja
einige vernünftige vorschläge gemacht
es braucht eine lobby auch die kinder
ganz ganz so ist es auf jeden fall keine
frage es ist aber finde ich persönlich
wenn ich jetzt kurz also wenn sie jetzt
runter reduziere auf mich auf meine
situation jetzt ja natürlich wissen wir
das ist eine ganz andere lage als ganz
viele andere familien das haben
nichtsdestotrotz gehe ich abends oft ins
bett mit kopfschmerzen mit schlechtem
gewissen
ich saß neulich heulend neben der
waschmaschine weil ich einfach nicht
mehr weiter wusste ich wusste nicht was
ich jetzt machen soll was es jetzt
wichtig da muss ich ran da muss ich ran
hier muss ich ran
es muss alles trotzdem perfekt sein ich
war wirklich ich habe einfach wirklich
gemerkt hat langer langer zeit bin ich
maßlos überfordert
und das ist ein stress den ich mit
nehmer und er tut mir nicht gut aber es
geht glaube ich vielen von uns so also
dieser ausnahmezustand
und dieser bruch der ist da und ich
finde immer noch gerade morgens und
abends am schlimmsten
und dass wir irgendwie lernen irgendwie
damit zurechtzukommen aber gerade auch
für kinder mit all ihren bedürfnissen
dem gerecht zu werden auch als mutter
bei meiner schwester zum beispiel dies
kein mathegenie in dem sinne und dann
auch so an seine eigene überforderung
erinnert zu werden es ist verdammt hart
gegenwärtig und das bringt auch nichts
erhält jetzt schöner zu reden als sie
ist trotzdem versucht deswegen wissen
wird auf seine art und weise natürlich
ein bisschen schöner zu gestalten
hannover sachen für sich zu entdecken
die einem vielleicht gut tun gibt unter
anderem auf endorphine freisetzen
[Musik]